Welcome back everyone this will be my brand new
netflix stranger things season 4 trailer
this is actually just for part one if you guys
didn't see the news they broke the season into
two parts but season 5 will be the final season
so season four here is not going to be the end
of the story everyone in the group going their
separate ways after season 3 queue up the journey
so i will talk about all the easter eggs there is
a lot of easter eggs a lot of 80s nostalgia going
on in the trailer a lot of music so we'll break
it all down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos real quick
reminder the first half of the episodes will start
airing at the end of may at the end of spring in
the last trailer that they released showing 11
over in california it was labeled hello california
but it was also her being hyped up to see him
finally because they were getting ready for spring
break so part of the idea is that i think a lot
of this is going down during spring break like
the war that they talk about the war with the
upside down in the war with the mind flayer who's
kind of like their version of freddy krueger now
big surprise too robert englund himself is in
season four part one i don't know if he's gonna
make it to season four part two so everybody
pour one out for him just in case the other big
easter egg too because most of you know him as a
version of freddy krueger from the nightmare on
elm street series a lot of the trailer does have
nightmare on elm street vibes with them going to a
different dimension quote unquote like the dream
warriors in the freddy krueger series to fight
a version of a villain before he takes over their
dimension too like freddy krueger was trying to do
but also robert englund in the trailer has
his eyes taken out and sewed shut because
the whole idea in the freddy krueger neighbor
on elm street series is that nobody could fall
asleep or freddy krueger would get you i'm not
exactly sure who he's supposed to be playing
so you can post all your theories about that but
he's just one of the other big 80s references
because the nightmare on elm street series was
huge in the 80s the other big thing too is that
the music track that they use on this trailer is
journey’s separate ways because the group has gone
separate ways they released four separate posters
they showed everybody in four different groups
like 11 is in this hallway that looks kind of like
the hawkins laboratory except a lot of the footage
you see her in is in the desert over in california
in this other government facility there's footage
of her going back with the hawkins laboratory
people like she's sad and mike is watching her
go away with these people so it's possible that
the short hair 11 scenes could be in present day
like they could shape her hair again and put her
back in that gear that we saw in during season one
but at least some of the season will be
flashbacks to her in the laboratory during
season one doing all this stuff at the beginning
of the story but the actual trailer starts at the
end of season three showing you that broken
reactor that the russians tried to activate
the voiceover that says you've broken everything
your suffering is almost at an end and then shows
that creepy clock and the haunted house that we
got footage of earlier i'll talk about that too
the voiceover is coming from this brand new freddy
krueger type of villain that they show you at the
end of the trailer who's basically telling them
the war is here your time is at an end but like
i said they're basically trying to give you a more
humanoid villain for them to fight and obviously
that will carry over into season four part two
and then whatever's happening during season five
but part of the idea during the freddy
krueger series is that the children couldn't
fully fight freddy krueger until like the dream
warriors for instance killed him inside the
dream dimension there are a couple moments
in the trailer to sort of hype up the group
all heading into the upside down they went their
separate ways talk about journey references then
to come back together eventually inside the upside
down fighting this war then the trailer shows max
billy's grave back in hawkins talking about
everything that's happened since the time
jump at end of season 3. everything has gone bad
it also shows her floating in the sky later with
the others that stayed in hawkins the new group
that they're calling the hellfire club so to speak
most of you know the hellfire club because of all
the x-men references it's a big group during the
x-men comics they show them during the x-men first
class movies but the whole idea with the dungeons
and dragons references through all the different
seasons of stranger things is that all the
challenges that they face during their dungeons
and dragons games season to season or references
to all the different villains that they fight
from the upside down including the mind player
so like the skull with the bolt of lightning in
the wings through it is a reference to this new
freddy krueger type of villain that they fight in
the form of the mind flair in this humanoid body
and the bats themselves with the actual wings i
also wouldn't be totally surprised if he himself
also sprouted wings just because creations of
the upside down have so many weird crazy powers
there's also a couple flashes of red lightning
inside the upside down when the bats first appear
all the kids are obviously way older now like you
look at them back during season one they look like
babies compared to how old they are now part of
the idea with them filming season five really soon
after season four is because the kids are getting
so much older not that it's a huge problem but it
is incredibly noticeable like they're all now
legit in high school or either getting ready to
graduate the older kids don't seem that much older
now mike is wearing the hellfire club shirt with
dustin and they're in the crowd watching lucas
play on the basketball team getting all hyped
up for him so there's some regular stuff going on
but remember this is all leading up to the events
of spring break where things really tip off in the
war quote unquote begins with the upside down
i've already talked about all the references
the journey's separate ways referencing how
the groups split up going their separate ways also
referencing hopper over in siberia russia you'll
learn a little bit of what's going on there max
winds up finding the mystery clock embedded in the
wall of their school back in hawkins it seems like
there just wind up being a bunch of weak points in
the different places where everyone is leading to
the dimension of the upside down so they can all
eventually reunite even though all the different
parts of the group are all over the world
and we see mike with will and his brother so
he might have just gone to visit 11 during
their spring break like i said paul reiser's dr
owen character comes back he talks about how he
basically sent them or their part of the group to
california to protect them but the war that he's
talking about is the war with the upside down like
things between our reality in the upside down are
getting crazier and eventually the mind flare
will be able to fully enter our dimension and
take over but the war the conflict that he keeps
talking about in the separate ways is also meant
to be an easter egg for the cold war in real life
that was happening during this part in history
between the united states and the soviet union
because remember the soviet union didn't break
up till the early 90s 11 tries to tell him that
her powers are gone but we do see max floating
in the air above billy's grave back in hawkins
and there was this last trailer a little while ago
all about 11's powers eventually coming back so
i think her powers being gone is more of a mental
thing and that will slowly work itself out through
the course of season four part one like i said her
going back with the hawkins laboratory people
winding up in this other facility seems like
it'll be where she discovers that her powers are
not totally gone but for at least a little while
at least in the first couple of episodes of the
first episode she will think that her powers are
still gone like she'll think that she's a regular
person now clearly it's not going to end up that
way though the whole thing with the haunted house
is they actually released a trailer a little while
ago we keep seeing versions of it inside the
upside down with the bats when they start to
go crazy but in the real world version of it in
hawkins you see the dungeons and dragons group
dusty and the others go to investigate it we got a
much more extended scene of what happened at this
house and why it is basically like their version
of a haunted house kind of like you see inside
the freddy krueger nightmare on elm street movies
basically a long time ago in the history of this
area in hawkins a family moved in and the father
wound up going crazy and killing the entire family
and it turned into this big local legend haunted
house kind of place but because of all the creepy
shots of the clock in the version in the upside
down with this new freddy krueger looking version
of the mind flare in this humanoid body this is
clearly just going to be one of the weak points
like you see nancy and steve reunite for the
first time in a while remember they used to go out
at the very beginning of the series until quote
unquote they went their separate ways so make more
journey references saying see you on the other
side and then them fighting inside the upside down
the person playing the metal guitar on top of the
house inside the upside down even though it seems
kind of ridiculous is probably just doing that
to create some noise to distract all the bats
in the creatures inside the upside down that
they're trying to fight there's a really quick
flash in a couple of what look like different
entry points between different dimensions like
you see a bunch of different points here that
seem like the different groups heading into the
upside down through different weak points with
different numbers attached to each different
place which seem like they correspond to some of
the creepy clocks that you see in the trailer
this one reads 146 the other is 33 then 52
and 230. we get a bunch more footage of hopper
fighting with the other prisoners against this
white demogorgon that the russians were keeping
to eat other guards eat other prisoners just at
whim it seems like they were keeping it as a pet
it seems like he's trying to help orchestrate some
sort of prison break in siberia russia but also it
looks like will's mother gets murray's help in
going to save him in russia because you see them
in this small plane with the snow all around them
but even though it seems like everything is going
crazy and there's this brand new villain from the
upside down or brand new form of the mind flare
inside this humanoid body that they're getting
ready to fight it's just the first half of season
four and season four itself like even both parts
is not the final season so if you spotted any big
easter eggs in the trailer that i didn't talk
about in the video just write them below in the
comments and i'll try to address them i've already
done a bunch of videos for the other stranger
things season 4 trailers they've released
so i'll link those below in the description
my new moon knight episode 3 video will post
next just like normal that'll be wednesday
morning so make sure you have alerts enabled
for my channel so you don't miss anything
and we will see more stranger things season
4 trailers as we get closer to the episodes
actually dropping everyone click here for
my brand new moon night episode 3 video
and click here for my brand new dr
strange 2 trailer video and easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!